alright guys so earlier this week I was
at the premiere here in Hollywood Los
Angeles for the no safe spaces
documentary this is a movie that's been
about two and a half years in the works
by two buddies of mine Dennis Prager
who's obviously been on this show many
times and I've been on his radio show a
gajillion times and done some videos for
Prager you and Adam Carolla who's also
been on this show and I've been on his
show a bunch of times
the premise of the movie all started
about three or four years ago when as I
know you guys are well aware a lot of
this campus craziness started and I'm
not just talking about protests but all
the things that you guys know about I'm
talking about riots and attacking police
officers and destroying public property
and stopping speakers from coming to
campus or literally locking speakers in
rooms or attacking professors or deep
platforming people or a series of the
other things that I've been talking
about on this show for a while so the
movie after about two years in the works
finally debuted here in Los Angeles
I'll pimp it out again later but you can
go to no safe spaces dot-com to find out
where the the movies premiering in your
city or hopefully close by you guys
they're still working on getting wide
release but in the first theater that
they premiered in it already had that I
think the second highest gross returns
for a documentary of all time after
Michael Moore is sicko anyway so I saw
it this week and there were a bunch of
people at the at the red carpet premiere
a lot of my crew was there from ben
shapiro and larry elder and and just a
series a bunch of guys Andrew Clayman
was there and Kurt Schlichter and a
whole bunch of people but the movie
itself and this is why I'm doing the
video the movie was spectacular it
really was like watching sort of all of
the things that I've been talking about
in this room for the last couple years
sort of all kind of pieced together so
the movie talks about the Brett
Weinstein Heather huiying debacle
basically at Evergreen State that I know
you guys are well aware about where they
basically protested a day where white
people were not
he allowed would not be allowed to come
to campus which was a flip on a
tradition that they had at Evergreen for
many years where one day a year black
students would not come to campus to
protest what they believed to be
perceived racism or racism of the past
Bret never had a problem with that
heather never had a problem with that in
the past but this year to tell students
that they couldn't come to school
because of the color of their skin they
did feel that was racist and of course
it is and they basically got chased off
campus Brett and Heather both lost there
in effect what were tenured positions
and they had to settle with the school
for $500,000 which sounds like a lot of
money right everyone would love 500
grand but that's for two professional
people with children who had tenured
positions at at a school so that talks
about that it talks about the Jordan
Peterson story fighting bill c-17 in
Canada about the trans pronouns he talks
about Lindsay Shepard who's been on the
show who was the student at Wilfrid
Laurier University who all she did was
in a class show a video of Jordan
Peterson and she was taken in by the
diversity crew or whatever you want to
call the diversity department at the
University and basically lambasted and
how she and Jordan ended up in lawsuits
with the university they talked about
the six hundred thousand dollars that it
took to secure Berkeley University so
that the very scary Ben Shapiro could
speak there and they they go on the
ground and they show you footage on the
ground and they do some fun animated
things and and a whole bunch of other
stuff but it was really interesting to
me because you know in the now it's a
little bit over four years that I've
been doing this this version of the
Reuben report it was really in September
of 2015 when I started doing this show
as a long-form interview show and I'm
sure many of you guys remember that
original interview with Sam Harris and
it was just like wow so many of the of
the people that I have talked to in this
room have been going through this and
and you know I've been through versions
of this about three years ago I spoke at
UCLA with Miley innopolis it feels like
a lifetime ago already and you know
students outside were we're throwing
things and they created a human chain
so none of us could get in they created
what was a human wall in effect so I
guess they're not really against walls
they just don't like Trump's wall but
you know they were pulling fire alarms
and there were bomb threats and students
screaming and all of these things and it
was interesting because Milo even said
to me in the midst of the whole thing
he's like you know if they would if the
protesters really weren't here I guess I
wouldn't be here either but there's so
many interesting things Brett makes a
really great point about this at the at
the end of the movie and I don't want to
give away too much because I really do
hope you guys will see it cuz it felt
important it was it was important and
edgy and real and it's also funny at
times but Brett makes a really
interesting point that you know it seems
like oh it's like these academics and
the YouTube crew they're so focused on
the college students and why are you
focusing on 18 19 21 year olds and it's
like there's actually a reason for that
and the reason for that is that these
kids that are in school now and they are
kids in effect these are kids who go to
a school to learn from adults right
they've sort of removed all the adults
from the equation we're now
administrators and college staff and
professors are cowed into silence and
there's many examples that they show
this in the movie and the problem is
that in the place where students are
supposed to learn the most that is
supposed to be the reverse of a safe
space right you're supposed to go to
college you have a sort of limited set
of ideas that you've learned as a young
person and that you've learned through
high school and whatever your family has
taught you whatever your ethnic
background is or religious beliefs or or
a religious beliefs whatever they are
you go to college and then you're
supposed to learn a wide variety of
things you're supposed to be hit with
new ideas you're supposed to be smacked
with things that will challenge you and
all those things and what's happened is
as we've removed that from the equation
and we've said to people you're not
going to be offended here you're not
going to be challenged here all of those
things what do you think you're really
doing I mean for the people this is a
perfect example of the phrase that I say
all too often which is that the road to
hell is paved with good intentions right
like so I believe that the people who
set up safe spaces the people who
instigate trigger warnings meaning that
if you walk into a class there will
actually be a sign outside of the class
and the sign will say you might hear
something about
violence or about gender or some other
scary topic you might hear some version
of these things and that you should just
watch out before you sit down but the
more that we do this book the more that
we give these kids spaces where they'll
never be challenged the more that we
warned them about potentially things
that might offend them what do you think
you're doing to these kids you're
actually whacking them in the knees
you're hitting them in the knees with a
baseball bat before you send them out to
the world because then they get out to
the world and the world is a messed up
scary place where you have to fight for
yours and you have to be ready to engage
with people who are different than you
and all of those things so I just really
felt like the movie was such a beautiful
mosaic of the things not only that I
care about and talk about but of so many
of the people who I love and admire who
have been here that I've had important
conversations with and I hope you guys
will check it out and you know I can
tell you as someone even now that you
know I speak at college campuses
probably four or five times a month I'm
actually as we take this right now I'm
heading out to Sacramento State tonight
it's like I find most of the students
that come to my events now I get it it's
a selected group of people right because
if you basically like me you're sort of
relatively open-minded you're willing to
talk about you know the differences that
we may have on important issues like
abortion or on taxes or whatever it
might be and you're willing to agree to
disagree
but I find just in the last couple weeks
I did High Point University I did
Liberty University and what I found is
that most students they don't want to be
treated like children now again it's a
self-selected group that comes to my
thing so maybe the students that are
outside of that they really do but it's
really not for the students to decide we
need more adults in the room and that's
what the movies about one of the
scariest things that they point out in
the movie is that right now a polls show
I think it was a Pew poll that they
referenced that over 50% of college
students believe that free speech
shouldn't include hate speech which the
statement itself doesn't even make sense
because a the Supreme Court has said
there's no such thing as hate speech we
have very limited protections around
speech you can't yell fire in a crowded
theater you can't incite to violence but
hate speech anything could be defined as
hate speech hate speech is an amorphous
term that anyone can use to say anything
about anybody so it'll be like someone
to be like oh you will you can't use
hate speech but you're a Nazi well it's
in that hate speech I mean we create
this really we
system of pressures that that doesn't
really make sense but the idea that
young people think that there that a
there should be hate speech laws in that
free speech that the First Amendment in
effect shouldn't protect against hate
speech that's exactly what the First
Amendment is for we've got the document
we've got the number one amendment in
the Bill of Rights that enshrines our
ability to battle it all out so that
we're not killing each other on the
streets and that's what we've done here
in America better than anywhere else so
if any of this makes any sense to you
check out the movie I normally don't do
a promo like this I'm also in it I'm
pretty I'm pretty good if I do say so
myself but there's there's liberals in
it there's conservatives in it there's
libertarians there's academics there's
comedians it's really really great check
out no safe spaces calm if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about free speech instead
of non-stop yelling check out our free
speech playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlists
there all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell